i'm a little
talked out after the candidates after
the
magnus carlsen invitational after the
feeder nations cup and the steiner's
invitational but
that will not stop me from dropping more
it's not real knowledge but more dead
jokes starting tomorrow
with the lynn dorris abbey
rapid challenge the next event in the
magnus carlson tour
where i think magnus carlsen is playing
um
it's 12 players to start with they play
a round robin
and then eight move on eight qualify
for the quarter finals where the top
finisher in the round robin plays
against the eighth finisher
two versus seven three versus six and
i'll leave it to you to figure out
who plays against four then
a new twist
where cynics might say
that increases magnus magnus carson's
chances to win the tournament
but really that increases the best
players chances to win the tournament
is that it's not just one knockout match
but it's best of
three it's like in basketball
it's three days of matches
and the first sight to score two and a
half points
out of the four game mini matches gets
one point
sounds confusing it's not that confusing
it's basically like nba playoffs that i
still hope we will get to see
this year i'll be doing commentary i'll
be in and out
um but there are
some heavy hitters there we got the
peters we get the lego peter
the swiddler peter bad news for you guys
we have to get the the trends
the lawrence trent i don't know any
other trends as you can see
by my attire um
and there might be some
more more or less special guests
and commentators so i think it will be
fun we will see
and how much everyone has left in the
tank but
this is not the times to complain about
working from my basement
we are blessed to have stuff to do in
these strange times
what's up chad boys
i should at some point talk about the
position right i'm doing very well here
due to the fact
that i'm a better chess player than
chuck barkley
i claim the mighty arms are saying are
you growing garden yetian
i've been growing a garden for a while
i'm thinking about becoming a full-time
prepper i have a little i'm always
confused you wouldn't call it garden in
english right you call it yard like
space outside where you can
shoot intruders that's the definition i
believe joking joking
um so i have that
i don't think i'm growing anything
useful there
probably not a good time to start
growing potatoes if i
am correctly informed about the news
coming out of canada holland
washington and so on so forth so maybe
tomatoes
is that a thing
[Music]
oh look at me
quincy one dr maneuveros
can't finally take some of your things
chuck barley
you kind of pinned aren't you
just in case just in case
i'm enjoying this game chuck sorry
you're so tied up
i haven't seen anybody as tied up since
that torture scene
um with daniel craig
it's family show so i'm not going to
elaborate
was a ballsy scene
all right is it time to cash in
i don't want to cash in my position is
so pretty
like knight f6 or something
i'd rather continue to play
oh okay now is the time
chucky
hmm
[ __ ]
hmm i messed this up so
sad why do i always mess everything up
it was such a nice game then i had to do
this
when all i wanted is to destroy
something beautiful
and i managed